maurepas 18 1543 habitants dans cette
commune et quatre candidats se
présentent chargé de communication
territoriale grégory gars restiez
s'engage en politique à l'âge de 16 ans
il est élu maire de nos repas lors du
scrutin en 2014 et fait basculer la vie
la droite la continuité d'avoir réveillé
notre belle endormie puisque maurepas
quant aux choix et aux responsabilités
avaient besoin justement de changement
d'avoir un nouveau dynamisme ce que nous
avons engagé avec mon équipe et puis
c'est la volonté aussi de continuer à
bien gérer notre commune on s'est
désendetté de 30% depuis le début du
mandat autres candidats se présentaient
à maurepas michel chapa ancien adjoint
au maire avant 2014 ici âge actuellement
dans l'opposition il n'a pas souhaité
répondre à nos questions au cours de
cette campagne proche et premier adjoint
de grégory gars restiez pendant six ans
erwan le gall présente sur cette
mandature sa propre liste il dirige
depuis 2015 un cabinet de conseil faire
des propositions pour la commune avec
des coûts financiers maîtrisé voilà ça
c'est un axe important il n'est pas
question d'aller partir de partir sur
des projets démesurés pour que les
impôts et la fiscalité démord pas il
s'enflamme ismaila vannes est à nouveau
tête de liste après 2014 le conseiller
municipal d'opposition se représente
ingénieur en électronique informatique
qu'il vit sur saint quentin en yvelines
depuis l'âge de 4 ans il s'engage dans
la jeunesse socialiste vers 16 ans
chaque projet
dans un quartier doit être au préalable
discuter avec les habitants des
quartiers pour avoir leur avis bien
avant que ça passe en conseil municipal
donc pour faire cela ce que nous avons
pris comme décision dans notre projet
c'est de créer les comités de quartier
qui permettront d'avoir un référent par
quartier mais surtout de pouvoir
discuter des projets en amont